you you've been to cern
in switzerland for people listening can
you explain
what cern is so cern
uh which basically for stands for
conceal
european paula recess nuclear uh
basically means the commission uh
european commission for nuclear research
so in essence um i can make a really
short answer and say it's one
big place where they do
nuclear research or physics research
and give you slightly longer answer is
that really it's a
bunch of scientists who set up this
multinational
institution to explore better
a better understanding of what matter is
and what
what we're made up of so um
you know if we're driven
i think as as humans to learn more about
our world
and whether it is okay you know 500
years ago
um we have you know the sailors i wanted
to explore the other side of the ocean
what's on the other side of the ocean
you know people were going into africa
we you know you know the old
cliche dark africa you know i want to
explore what that is and then we've got
you know
aspects of nature and how how you know
what is
um the fundamental reason why we have
living things the way
we do we have charles darwin and of
course the discovery of
you know dna and so forth and in terms
of
physics we're dealing with or what is
the matter that we're made up of
and you know if we boil it down what is
it made of and so cern is just one
progression step
of that in terms of a better
understanding of how it works so
in a simplistic term
the way that we often understand what
matter is made up of is to smash it
so hit it with particles and smash it up
and see what those particles
look like when they come off um and
the discovery of the electron was
basically that
um you know basically firing a beam and
what
and and watching it what happens to it
um
and um cern is just
magnifying that so in essence
cern is not just the large hadron
collider a lot of people think that soon
is just that large ring
cern actually existed since 1954
with different particle accelerators or
particle colliders
and the idea again is fire particles at
mata and see what sprays off and if you
look and measure what
sprays off you can understand what the
structure is that you
were smashing it into so yeah so what
is the large hydraulic collider the
large hadron collider yep how do you say
it
hadron hadron yeah but i'll explain that
yeah alex what does that mean okay so
large hadron collider really is a part
of
the institution of cern which is the
basically in french the
version of the european commission for
nuclear research okay
and in essence cern is a physics
institute that was set up in the
early 50s and supported by
a number of member countries basically
based in europe
and the idea with cern
is to understand what matter is so
really what drives cern and drives any
scientific endeavor is
discovering more about our world and how
it works so
you know you've got of course in the
1500s you've got the sailors moving
across the oceans
what's on the other side you've got the
astronomers looking up to the sky what
is making up the stars and how does it
move and so forth and you know we've got
newton
for example and understanding you know
their understanding of gravitation and
so forth
you know you've got scientists like
darwin with uh how
life evolves and you've got scientists
like watson crick and
and others who look at what's the
fundamental nature of
you know life the dna aspect and so
with physicists they're understanding as
well what particularly with particle
physicists is what's the
fundamental nature of matter you know we
brought it down to atoms but then we say
well hold on
we discovered atoms are made up of other
particles
and we call them protons and neutrons
and electrons well that was
discovered in the early part of the 20th
century
through experiments that are often
referred to as scattering experiments or
collision experiments um and
um and how that all works is you know
obviously the drives what scientists
don't know
no more but then what happened is
that they discovered that when they were
looking at particles and and and you
know it's basically
um seeing their behavior in certain
experiments they discovered that a whole
bunch of particles they could not be
explained by
using that idea of you know an atom is
made up of a proton a neutron an
electron
and so the quest was driven to say well
can we learn
more about what the proton than the
neutron is for example are they
what we refer to as fundamental
particles are they truly
indivisible right or or
are they themselves made up of smaller
particles still
and so cern developed a whole series of
what we call
particle accelerators or scattering
experiments which basically
is really simple you know
if you smash things together and we're
able to
um watch the particles that come off
then you have a better understanding of
the conditions of
what you were smashing you know it's
sort of like
it's a poor analogy in one sense but
it's basically a
uh let's say a uh an investigator for
in a car crash you know they don't see
the car crash
all they see is the particles strewn
everywhere but if you analyze the
particles
then you can work out how fast was that
car going
what was the other car doing at the time
in the collision
right so by looking at the remnants of
the collision
you can have a better understanding of
what occurred at the collision and what
was involved in the collision
and that's really what particle
accelerators do but in this set we're
not smashing cars together
we're smashing particles together such
as electrons such as
protons and
and then seeing what comes off and then
as a result
you can get an understanding of what
makes up those particles
so the more energy you put into the
system the more energy you can smash
those particles
the more understanding you can have
about what you're investigating
so in the case of the large hydrogen
corridor which is basically the largest
particle accelerator in the world
um it's basically smashing protons
together and and then seeing what comes
off that
and when you measure what comes off that
you have an understanding of what
well first of all what the protons are
but also what is the fundamental nature
of those protons now this is where the
term comes in a proton
is simply what we refer to as a generic
term of a hadron so a hadron is
basically
uh a type of particle we now know that
is made
up of uh what we refer to as quacks
you may have heard the term before cork
or quark but in essence we know that a
proton and a neutron are made up of
quarks
and both of them are made up of three
quarks
and so anything that is made up of
quarks is called a hadron
and so that's why we call the large
hadron collider we could call the large
proton collider but it doesn't have to
be a proton
it could be something else but
um it's using a proton because protons
are easily produced basically
hydrogen is our main source of protons
so just a a gas of hydrogen um
gas is you know basically all that is
injected into the large hydrogen
collider because basically that's what
the hydrogen is
a bunch of protons um and how what's the
scale of this thing
okay yep so um again cern is a very
large place but the large hadron
collider
itself is a ring um
that is buried 100 meters under under
the ground
the ring is 27 kilometers in
circumference
and in that you have these two beams of
protons
spinning around at close to the speed of
light
and they're um the
at four points on that ring are what we
call particle detectors so
the two beams are in two separate tubes
going in opposite directions around this
27 kilometers track
and there are basically bunches of
protons
spinning around now the numbers are
mind-boggling so
each bunch that spins around
contains about 100 billion protons
all right and you've got another 100
billion protons going in the opposite
direction like this
now it's not just one bunch but there's
actually a whole
series of bunches um about separated
about seven and a half meters around
the tube and
then um they spin so fast
that they go around that ring 11 245
times per second so yeah it's pretty
fast right so
the number i always like the quote is
okay they travel
at the speed just shy of the speed light
99.9999991
percent of the speed of light now to
give you a perspective of how fast that
is
um if you were to run around the world
at that speed
you could go around the world seven and
a half times in one second
so um you know it's incredibly fast
so what happens is that those particles
are now traveling so fast when you
smash them and this happens at what we
call
detectors and there are four of them on
the ring
they basically make these two paths in
cross over
so that these two bunches now meet at
the detector
and then hopefully these bunches will
have some collisions of these protons
and
of the hundred billion coming one way
and about a hundred billion going the
other way
you may get only a billion collisions in
that
around or even less right you don't get
many collisions
going on um but when i do happen
um like the car crash you can measure
what comes off it
and those detectors are basically
glorified
machines that measure how fast they're
going and what direction that they're
going
of the particles and if you can measure
that then you can
we'll work out what's going on here in
terms of what those
what the collision entails and so um
in essence you know it's a better
understanding of
what how matter works what's the nature
of matter